here we go game three of the NBA Finals
Elkins is too big and too strong
Jamal Murray from downtown
let's make it 20 rebounds for the Joker
he had another triple double rebound and
that is a triple double for Drury the
smile on your face we saw History Two
teammates with 30-point triple doubles
regular season or playoffs it's never
happened before
I've been lucky to be around shacking
when I made my finals run but you're
around the Joker what y'all did in game
three is historical the way you're
playing you may look easy can you
explain why you guys get along so well
just trying to win the game we're both
trying to win a game and and we both
understand it may not be you that has to
make the play if I'm open I know York's
gonna find me if he's open he knows I'm
looking for him we both trust each other
enough to get the job done
Maurice connects on a three
you're a historians not too many MVPs
that say I have my closer back how's
that make me feel from growing up I'm
dreaming about being that guy making
tough shots down the stretch so to be
able to be here and impact the game is
all I can ask for and we have been
keeping the right mentality this whole
time night in and night out whether we
play well or not big bucket from Murray
performance unbelievable tally on
display from Murray your relationship
with your dad having you outside
shooting jump shots in the snow how did
that help you with your toughness I just
love basketball I think that's where a
lot of it stems from but push-ups in the
snow and running hills that obviously
builds toughness and character love to
see the Improvement of myself it was
just this is what I have to do to get
better this is what I'm willing to do so
I'm appreciative of those moments my dad
pushed me to my limit during those times
Murray's down and hurt oh my goodness oh
Jamal Murray is in massive pain that did
not look good for Jamal Murray I think
rehab was tough because I had to
mentally just keep a consistent Trends
it wasn't like okay today I feel good
I'm gonna do this it was like I have to
keep even kill the whole two years that
was tough watching the team go through
their ups and downs and I'm just
watching and trying to stay patient
can't affect the result right now there
was times where I got super eager just
like man I can't even hold myself back
but now playing is pretty special
and obliterating the Lakers there was a
sequence in the Laker series I think you
ran off three or four threes in a row
you gave me that Jamal Murray look how
that feel I felt good from playing with
confidence like that you know I don't
feel like there's anybody can stop me so
that's a good time for my teammates if
I'm feeling like that it's just a lot of
fun just being that competitive mode
again it was nice to put myself back in
that competitive spirit and just let
loose
a masterpiece from the Holyoke
details is it slowing down Jimmy or
making sure you guys don't get a wide
open three-point shot I mean they got
some really good shoes over there Jimmy
Eat 56 points before in the playoffs
that's a lot of points a lot of points
so if he's getting going and they got
shoes on the court it's tough so we
gotta be able to take away both a lot of
one-on-one defense AEG is doing a great
job they're in the best player being a
selfless guy kcp's boosts your energy
every night on defense they bring it and
we need that for two more games and get
the job done
[Music]